ONE RULE FOR DEMOCRATS IN THE
SWAMP AND ONE RULE FOR THE REST
OF US.
HERE FOR REACTION, GREG JARRETT
ALONG WITH FORMER FLORIDA
ATTORNEY GENERAL PAM BONDI.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TONIGHT
.
GREG, YOU HAD A GREAT PIECE ON
THE FOXNEWS.COM TALKING ABOUT
THE CONSTITUTIONAL HURDLES HAVE
THIS.
WHAT WAS THAT PESKY DOCUMENT
THAT THEY WISH THEY CAN SECURE
INVENT IT AGAIN, IT MIGHT BE TH
ONE THING STANDING BETWEEN US
AND THE GUN GRAB RID.
>> IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE THAT
EMOTIONS ARE RUNNING HIGH END
EMOTION SOMETIMES LEAD TO ACTION
, BUT THOSE ACTIONS AREN'T
ALWAYS LAWFUL, JOE BIDEN CAN
DEMONIZE THE GUN MANUFACTURERS
AND REPUBLICANS ALL HE WANTS,
THAT'S NOT HIS PROBLEM, THE
PROBLEM IS THAT PESKY DOCUMENT
CALLED THE CONSTITUTION AND
SPECIFICALLY THIS AND CAN
AMENDMENT THE LANDMARK OR
DECISION, THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT INVALIDATED THE
INDIVIDUAL RIGHT TO KEEP AND
BEAR ARMS.
THEY SAID SOME LIMITED
REGULATIONS ARE PERMISSIBLE AND
THEN THEY NAMED THEM KEEPING
GUNS OUT OF THE HANDS OF FELONS
IN THE MENTALLY ILL, AWAY FROM
SCHOOLS AND GOVERNMENT BUILDINGS
, BUT IT'S ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR THAT BEYOND THAT, DOING
WHAT BIDEN WANTS TO DO, WHICH I
TO BAN AN ENTIRE CLASS OF
WEAPONS OWNED BY 15 MILLION
AMERICANS WOULD NOT PASS
CONSTITUTIONAL SCRUTINY, IN FAC
THE LIBERAL LEANING NINTH
CIRCUIT LAST MONTH STRUCK DOWN
CALIFORNIA'S BAN INVOLVING THE
SALE OF AR 15'S.
BIDEN KNOWS ALL OF THIS BECAUSE
IN HIS SPEECH NOT ONCE, BUT
TWICE LAST NIGHT HE SAID IF WE
CAN'T BAN ASSAULT WEAPONS, THEN
AND HE PROPOSED SOME FAIRLY
REASONABLE OTHER OPTIONS SUCH A
INCREASED SCHOOL SECURITY, RED
FLAG LAWS, BETTER BACKGROUND
CHECKS, AND SO FORTH.
THERE IS ACTUALLY SOME
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR THAT, BU
WHEN HE IS ASKING LAWMAKERS TO
DO APPEARS TO BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND LESS YOU
AMEND THE CONSTITUTION, BUT THA
REQUIRES A VOTE OF TWO THIRDS O
BOTH HOUSES, RATIFICATION BY
THREE QUARTERS OF THE STATE, AN
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN VERY.
>> AND EVERY TIME HE TALKS ABOU
IT IT DEMONIZES, HE ALWAYS GOES
AFTER THE STRONGMEN OF THE NRA,
THAT'S WHO HE LOVES TO TALK
ABOUT BUT EVEN DOING THAT IS
CONDESCENDING TO AVERAGE
AMERICANS WHO SIMPLY UNDERSTAND
THE CENTRALITY OF THE FIRST AND
SECOND AMENDMENTS, INDIVIDUAL
RIGHTS GIVEN TO EMPOWER
INDIVIDUAL FREE PEOPLE, THEY'VE
TOTALLY LOST SIGHT OF THAT AND
THEY WOULD GO THEY WOULD GO FOR
EVERY GUN IF THEY COULD.
>> THEY WOULD COME UP GREG,
THAT'S PIECE WAS INCREDIBLE THA
YOU PUT ON FOX NEWS TODAY I
THINK EVERYONE SHOULD GO ON AND
READ IT BECAUSE IT LAYS OUT
EXACTLY WHAT YOU JUST SAID, IT
IS A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT, IT IS
OUR RIGHT TO BEAR ARMS AND TO
DEFEND OURSELVES.
IT'S INTERESTING THAT JOE BIDEN
OF THE 80s WHO WE SEEM TO LIKE
A LOT MORE WHO SAID THAT YEAH,
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO TAKE GUNS
OUT OF THE HANDS OF CRIMINALS
WAS ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
WHEN I WAS A YOUNG PROSECUTOR
RAY BEFORE I WAS ATTORNEY
GENERAL IN MY EARLY 20s, I HAD
A STALKER FOR YEARS, I DON'T
TALK ABOUT IT A LOT, BUT I
LEARNED TO SHOOT FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT, THEY TAUGHT ME TO
SHOOT BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE THE
LUXURY THAT LORI CLINTON OR JOE
BIDEN HAS WHICH WAS FULL-TIME
PROTECTION I LEARNED TO SHOOT A
GUN TO PROTECT MYSELF.
MY SUIT STALKER ULTIMATELY
COMMITTED SUICIDE, BUT I DESERV
THE RIGHT TO PROTECT MYSELF AS
DO ALL AMERICANS IN THEIR HOMES
TO BE SAFE, AND THAT'S WITH THE
SECOND AMENDMENT SAYS AND THAT'
WHAT HELLER SAID LOUD AND CLEAR.
I FIND IT ASTONISHING THAT THEY
KEEP OUR BORDERS WIDE OPEN AND
THEY LET CRIMINALS COME INTO
THIS COUNTRY, THEY LET CARTELS
AND, THEY LET GANGS INCOMING IN
ILLEGAL GUNS ARE COMING INTO OU
COUNTRY THAT WAY, AND THAT'S
OKAY FOR THAT TO HAPPEN, BUT NO
FROM LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS TO
HAVE GUNS.
>> IT'S JUST LIKE SPEECH.
RED FLAG LAWS, THE IDEA THAT
SOMEONE ELSE GETS TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION, SOMEONE YOU DON'
KNOW, UNACCOUNTABLE TO YOU TO
MAKE THE DESIGNATION ABOUT
WHETHER THE SPEECH YOU ARE
SAYING IS ACCEPTABLE OR WHETHER
THEY GUN YOU WOULD LIKE TO OWN
IS WHEN YOU CAN OWN.
WE'RE ALL FOR THAT REALITY THAT
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE THAT
SHOULDN'T ON THEM, BUT IT ALL
COMES DOWN TO WHO THE DECIDER IS
.
TO GET YOUR ABSOLUTELY RIGHT,
WHICH IS WHY MANY OF THOSE CASES
, THERE IS MORE THAN A
DOZEN RED FLAG LAWS IN STATES
ALREADY IN THERE BEING LEGALLY
CHALLENGED AND WILL HAVE TO SEE
HOW THAT LITIGATION GOES FORWARD
, BUT, THERE ARE PROBLEMS
WITH SEVERAL OF THE IDEAS HE
PROPOSED LAST NIGHT, BUT THE
STRONGEST PROPOSAL HE HAD COME
UP MORE MONEY FOR COOL SECURITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHERE OUR
CHILDREN ARE LOCATED FOR SEVEN,
EIGHT, NINE HOURS A DAY, THAT
THEY ARE SAFE AND SECURE, THOSE
ARE THE BEST MEASURES AND I DO
AGREE THAT ADDED MONEY FOR
HEALTHCARE PROGRAMS WOULD ALSO
BE HELPFUL BECAUSE THAT IS A
COMMON DENOMINATOR THAT WE SEE
IN SO MANY OF THESE MASS
SHOOTINGS.
>> FOR SURE.
PAM, WE ONLY HAVE ABOUT 15
SECONDS.
WESTWARD.
GET THAT'S WHAT WE DID AFTER TH
PARKLAND SHOOTING, DO EVERYTHIN
WE COULD AND FLORIDA TO
STRENGTHEN OUR SCHOOLS, HARDEN
OUR SCHOOLS AND GIVE MORE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SECURITY AT EACH IN
EVERY SCHOOL IN OUR STATE AND W
NEED TO DO THAT THROUGHOUT OUR
COUNTRY TO PROTECT OUR CHILDREN.
>> IF YOU ACTUALLY WANT TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS AT HAND,
YOU'RE PRECISELY RIGHT VERY